hey guys today there's the 15th of July
my name is Jessa McDonald and he is a
bunch of knees a UK report has indicated
the game is still prefer buying boxed
copies over digital games broadband
Jeanie a uk-based ISP comparison website
conducted a survey which found that
among 2000 gamers thirty-nine percent
said they prefer to buy physical
software / digital comparatively
twenty-five percent said they prefer to
download their games and thirty-six
percent had no preference similarly in
against [ __ ] it was found that over
half of respondents preferred to buy
physicals and only a quarter said they
preferred digital here box is getting
started on a new Juke nukem game and
here's all the stuff you need to know
about that see ya Randy Pitchford may
have spent yesterday explaining how he
lost a 10 million of his own money to
funding aliens colonial Marines but
today things could be looking up
pitchford said that the studio has done
early concept work for a follow-up to
2011's wildly disappointing Juke nukem
forever as reported by IGN Pitchford has
said the company is on the lookout for
the right developer and that when the
game does happen quote the whole
industry will turn its head and look
gearbox is currently working on moba
esque shooter battle born a third
Borderlands game and potentially a new
brothers in arms Pitchford has said he
wants to continue with the Duke Nukem
franchise because it's popular with the
mainstream audience and that many only
cared about duke nukem forever because
of its unusually long 14 year
development schedule gamespot gave the
game a 3.5 out of 10 with reviewer kevin
vinod noting quote the bland and ugly
Duke Nukem Forever turns a famous gaming
icon into an embarrassment pitchford was
quoted as saying I did not acquire the
franchise melee so we could all
experience you can you confirm that was
a toll to pay to give Duke a chance the
new horizons space probe which passed by
Pluto is probably a thing you never
expected to hear about on gamespot news
but it turns out the thing uses the same
CPU at
the original PlayStation the verge
reports that the probe which beamed
brand new images of the dwarf planet
contains an MIP s r3000 CPU which was
repurposed to fire thrusters monitor
sensors and transmits data the CPU was
first released in 1994 and was used in
the original PlayStation before it was
implemented into the new horizons space
probe by NASA scientists the probe was
launched in 2006 but reportedly NASA
prefers reliable and tried and tested
tech / newer hardware let me know down
in the comments if you prefer to buy
physical or digital games and why you
can head to gain spot where we've got
stories on a fable legends release date
and a sweet sonic HD video that is
everything I want to tell you about
today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I'll catch you again
tomorrow